bon toujours j'arrose javaux à plein au
tout le temps et d'arroser ça n'est pas
faux je me venge en arrosant légion moi
mais je m'accroche ma peau je déteste la
pompe ou celui quand je vois des
secteurs dans vos avis croire quelque
chose pour infléchir tous ces pauses
je vous le raffinement
[Musique]
le 28 décembre 1895 la première séance
de projection publique de cinématographe
a lieu au salon indien du café de paris
il y a dix films d'une minute et parmi
ces films il y à une sorte d'ensemble de
ce qu'on peut faire avec le cinéma
il ya des vues militaire il y a des vues
spectaculaires et il y a des vues
comique est l'une de ces vieux comics
est évidemment la vue comique maîtresse
l'arroseur arrosé
[Musique]
il
à
d'évidence l'intérêt des spectateurs
c'est plutôt voir le fonctionnement de
la machine et voir ce qu'elle produit
mais l'intérêt est pas tellement dans la
dimension mondiale aujourd'hui
esthétique de ce qui est produit
c'est plutôt effectivement voir quelque
chose qui fonctionne et qu'on n'a jamais
vues avant donc finalement on pourrait
presque imaginer mais là ça semble un
peu la spéculation que peu importe ce
qu'on va voir
peu importe qu'on enregistre l'important
c'est quand récemment fonctionne et
qu'on puisse assister à cette
performance d'enregistrement reproduit
j'avais été très impressionné au du
fayel quand j'avais vu les premières
images de dutra de la ciotat mais je
dois dire la vérité que je t'avais
j'avais eu un étonnement mais j'avais
pas fait de déduction c'est également
parce que c'est elle est ce que je
voyais l'arroseur arrosé tout ça était
laid c'était vraiment du tout-venant
c'était là l'actualité pour ainsi dire à
peine transposée
[Musique]
une grande part du public qui a pu voir
les premières projections du
cinématographe lumière
en fait il était habitué à voir des
spectacles avec des images projetées
dans le noir est donc on oublie trop
souvent que il ya une antériorité avec
la lanterne magique par exemple donc de
nombreux spectacles de lanternes
magiques ont été proposées au public
depuis le 17e siècle mais en tout cas on
est sûrs au cours du xviiie siècle et
surtout pendant le 19e avec des
possibilités de faire bouger les
personnages ou bien les décors selon le
mouvement des plaques que le l'opérateur
de lanternes va faire et on se rend
compte qu'en fait le cinéma est
complètement mêlée avec un an dernier a
pas de différence on croit qu'on va
opposer fixes et animées mais on discute
de vue mouvementée pour les plaques
parce qu'il ya des ressorts parce qu'il
ya des manivelles et c est la différence
et pas du tout perçu de manière aussi
nette
on l'a reconstruit rétrospectivement le
fixe puis l'animé mais à l'époque
c'était surtout conçu dans un même
paradigme dans une même idée qui est la
projection et au sein de la projection
ce qui compte c'est qu'il ya une image
projetée si possible de bonne qualité
grande qu'ils puissent être vus par un
public collectif évidemment mais aussi
la présence d'une parole et finalement
le cinéma bien ce s'inscrire dans la
suite de la lanterne et donc ce qu'on
attend aussi c'est qu'ils soient
accompagnés par une voix
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs la dernière fois
vous vous en souvenez je vous ai exposé
les progrès de l'électricité aujourd'hui
je vais vous parler d'une autre
invention non moins phénoménal
le tuyau d'arrosage
et bien sachez mesdames et messieurs que
depuis que l'homme cultive
ils arrosent rappelez-vous les écrits de
pline l'ancien le temps d'arroser et le
matin et le soir afin que le soleil des
chauffe pas l'eau ainsi tout ce que l'on
repique de bien meilleures et plus gros
surtout les navets et poireaux mais
admettait de porter des arrosoirs le
long des années des potagers est une
corvée
avouez que l' usage du tuyau d'arrosage
rend la tâche beaucoup plus aisée il
faut le reconnaître
mettre au point un matériau qui soit à
la fois creux et d'anjou est solide et
est une gageur des plus ardues
[Musique]
bien que les frères lumière et et n'est
pas reconnu le fait qu'ils étaient
influencés par une bande dessinée
peut-être qu'ils s'en souviennent plus
que le processus qui les a menés à ce
scénario était un petit peu a effacé
peut-être cette référence mais en fait
l'arroseur arrosé la version de
christophe a été publié en 1889 pendant
l'exposition universelle de de paris ont
connu une version allemande entre les
versions espagnoles qui ont été reprises
ensuite dans des revues brésilienne donc
et même américaines évidemment donc le
gag a fait le tour du monde dans les
journaux de l'époque l'histoire de
l'arroseur arrosé a été présenté pour la
première fois dans les pages du flic de
blettes or c'est un magazine d'humour
allemand dont les américains et les
français vont en général s'inspirer
j'avais rechercher dans les flics and
letters l'origine du gag
je connaissais la date à 2,3 en prêt je
te regarde
et puis tout à coup je tombe sur
chenilles sman jeudi formidable jeu les
monts arroseur arrosé était très content
et puis je remonte par comme ça et de
poum juste avant je tombe sur robert
länder qui lui a fait un truc en deux
images et donc pendant longtemps j'ai
pensé que c'était eux qui étaient à
l'origine du gag
et puis en fait le français uzès a
semble-t-il lui l'a fait deux fois
et lui sa date la première note de 85
donc il est très très devant des autres
et donc lui donc c'était lui pour moi le
premier et puis non il ya un ami fake
est qu'il a fait avant alors c'est un
type qui s'appelle frost on sait qu'il
est paru dans un recueil qui s'appelle
stephen jones en 1884 vraisemblablement
il est paru dans la presse encore avant
mais peut-être qu'il y avait encore des
gens avant et je pense à conclusion mon
article tu veux faire dans papy nickelés
ça va être que l'inventeur du gag de
l'arroseur arrosé c'est l'inventeur du
kurde roz âge s'il nous faut chercher
l'origine du tuyau c'est vers la lutte
contre les incendies qu'il faut se
tourner jadis les moyens étaient tout à
fait revenir en terre les hommes se
munissent est simple seau d'eau du
crochet et 2h leurs interventions de
vains efforts au système sap et détruire
les parties environnants pour éviter la
propagation du feu les grecs dit on
aurait inventé trois siècles avant
jésus-christ une poupe primitive la cie
phone ce n'était en fait que les normes
seringue qui projette des lots aux lois
toutefois ce système reste est assez
laborieux et aux dires du bourgeois
ce n'était ni pratique ni efficace
beaucoup plus tard en 16 152 à amsterdam
ville d'art et de canaux jan van der
heijden alors âgé de 12 ans assiste
impuissant à l'incendié de la mairie
il est très impressionné et affecté à la
destruction de cet édifice flamboyant
vingt ans plus tard il invente la pompe
à bras
la fameuse pompe hollandaise puis il
confectionne un tuyau souple fait de
cuir cousu main et les sapeurs de
chandhok c'est mme berthe ainsi à pomper
pomper tant et si bien qu'ils aient 20
sapeurs pompiers
[Musique]
c'est l'âge d'or de l'invention à ce
moment là il était bricoleur partout il
ya des revues dans tous les grands
magazines on voit des diagrammes
montrant comment réaliser tel ou tel
bricolage astucieux pour résoudre tel ou
tel problème pratique
ouais
e
[Musique]
et
ces nouveaux objets qui sont créées
réapparaissent après dans les histoires
en mise en image et sa rue d'accessoires
pour faire des gags mais ça peut être
pris comme une critique de la modernité
finalement tuyau d'arrosage
comme l'appareil photo un bon ça
désavantage mais bon faut pas aussi s'en
servir pour en pot pour rien que le
record lointaine de kingston venait
d'être livré à la curiosité publique
nous avions remarqué mon foie rein mois
qu'on gagne il serait plus intéressant
dans la main sur un écran des filiales
et les droits de l'enfant allait
pénaliser les objets des grands
mouvements ce que lumière va inventer
c'est en fait le partage d'une seule et
même image sur l'écran par un public
collectif assis et qui regardent
ensemble la même image et évidemment ça
change tout parce qu'en réalité un film
vu seul est une curiosité un peu de
voyeurs alors que lorsque on passe un
film sur un écran
il y à un reer collectif une émotion
collective et sa lumière s'en aperçoit
d'entrée la boîte magique qui vous
projette ses images animées a bien
failli disparaître deux ans à peine
après son invention
c'était le 4 mai 1897
comme tous les ans à deux pas des champs
elysées
la foule se presse à la vente de
bienfaisance du bazar de la charité
entre monsieur lumière
un spectacle sensationnel vous verrez la
sortie des usines l'arrivée du train en
gare de la ciotat et surtout l'arroseur
arrosé est bien de l'arroseur arrosé ils
n'enverront pas une goutte
l'embuscade du destin était rapide le
petit réduit du cinématographe caprices
de la lampe à gaz auxi éthérée elle
s'éteint et se rallument excès de
pression du gaz
et voilà lincendie déchaîné
instantanément généralisée furieuse
incoercible
[Musique]
la quart d'heure il ne reste du bazar de
la charité la brasier noir funeste et
fumant le bilan est très lourd
126 morts dont 118 femmes et voilà le
cinématographe jugé trop dangereux
les projections sont officiellement
interdites
heureusement pour écarter tout risque
les projections se feront dorénavant
depuis une cabine spécialement aménagé
lorsque on produit l'arroseur arrosé
on n'imaginait pas encore que le cimade
va devenir le spectacle qu'il va devenir
peu de temps après donc il y aurait 10
prévus à d'autres temps très différent
très distinctes le premier temps qu'elle
dans lumière qui est un peu un temps où
on fait des films pour voir s'il ya un
public finalement c'est un petit peu ça
pendant trois quatre cinq ans disons à
peu près jusqu'à 1900 pathé va tourner
très peu gourmand on va tourner très peu
ils vont surtout essayer de vendre des
caméras et du matériel à partir de 1900
il ya une petite scansion les premiers
studios vont commencer à s'approprier la
production pathé gaumont d'autres
petites entreprises qui seront ensuite
absorbé
finalement il ya aussi de l'argent à
faire non plus sur le contenant ans
pendant des machines et des projecteurs
mais sur le contenu
d'autant que les projecteurs sont entre
les mains de personnes itinérantes donc
si on leur vend des projecteurs pourquoi
ne pas leur vendre les films qui vont
avec et comme ça les gens vont aller de
ville en ville et projeter les films
les films se complexifie on écrit on
fait de la production industrielle il
faut sortir de nouveaux films mais on
est toujours dans ce qu'on appelle un
cinéma primitif qui est un spectacle
éminemment fera entre 1900 et 1914 après
40 % de tout ce qui s'est produit comme
film en france et comique
en tout cas et ranger dans cette
catégorie scènes comiques ou qu'on
appelle parfois aussi comédie un peu
plus tard donc voilà il ya un genre
dominant c'est incontestable il est
certain que les la fin du xixème siècle
est une période inquiète qui a besoin de
rire
[Musique]
des centaines de cafés concerts à paris
les chansons et les pièces sont
principalement comique pantomine le sont
en tout cas et les clowns beaucoup de
spectacles donc son comique et puis le
premier cinéma est très largement pour
comprendre le mode de fonctionnement de
ce cinéma et empathique et du cinéma de
fiction comique de cette époque là il
faut comprendre que tous les
protagonistes qu'il soit un metteur en
scène qu'ils soient auteurs d'histoire
parce qu'on dit pas encore scénaristes
qui soient comédiens viennent de ces
autres pratiques spectaculaire et
artistique
c'est à dire que certains viennent du
théâtre viennent du music-hall viennent
du cirque tracts et des acrobates
beaucoup qui tourne des films comiques
et tout cela pour inventer des numéros
de cirque un numéro de musicaux sont
aussi des lecteurs de s'être de ces
revues comique et donc voilà il ya une
circulation on pourrait dire on dire
aujourd'hui un terreau médiatique entre
la presse la scène le cinéma mais qui se
fait naturellement parce que les gens
qui sont amenés à inventer ces films
viennent de là et donc se basent sur
leur expérience pratique antérieure pour
soi pour écrire soi pour jouer
soit pour mettre en scène il ya beaucoup
de numéros de cirque des choses qui sont
assez spectaculaires qui correspondent
aussi à l'idée de cinéma des attractions
et des attractions foraines donc des
jongleurs des magiciens
plusieurs héros de séries comiques
cinématographiques ont été déjà des
personnages du tien en particulier table
de café concert par exemple calinaud
dont on connaît bien les films calinaud
incarne pendant toute une partie du 19e
siècle le l'imbécile le naïf il apparaît
donc pas mal d'histoires calinaud se
marient la soeur de calino on va faire
la même observation pour boire au bois
roux est aussi un personnage qui
apparaît sur la scène du café concert et
qui est aussi un héros des histoires que
les rois les nouvelles à la main qui
paraissent dans le gil blas dans les
années 1880 action nombre des petites
histoires comiques
il ya d'autres exemples encore sont des
personnages qui ont une une vie
antérieure au cinéma
[Musique]
le clou de la séance de music-hall c'est
les films on a un jongleur une chanteuse
et hop on met un écran on projette le
film et l'a logiquement leur caisse de
music hall va continuer d'accompagner et
du coup tout ça va s'agréger de plus en
plus pour créer ce genre
cinématographique comique si on film
c'est comme le foot it et chocolat par
exemple si on voit que ça marche bien et
que le tourneur le forain ils voient que
ces films là ça marche bien il va y
avoir de la demande donc gomorra se dire
tiens on va en faire plus en plus c'est
pas tes aussi donc il ya des gens qui
vont se spécialiser là dedans ils vont
même créé une troupe qui s'appelle les
pouic qui est une troupe qui va faire
vraiment du comique costaud et on va
détruire les tables les assiettes les
armoires les carrément des étages qui
tombe dans un immeuble etc
tout ça parce que ça existe finalement
sous la forme spectacle de cabaret de
music-hall de cirque avec les clowns
c'est vrai qu'il ya un genre
cinématographique qui va naître
à partir de ce qui existe déjà
[Musique]
méliès il fait des numéros de magie au
lieu de les faire sur scène il va les
filmer et il valait projeté dans son
théâtre de magie donc le théâtre robert
houdin qui devient une salle de cinéma
permanent mais avec alternance
d'ailleurs de temps en temps quand même
avec des numéros de magie des pièces
magique encore de temps en temps mais la
voilà il fait des numéros de magie à cet
endroit là donc il va filmer un numéro
de magie beaucoup de choses dont on
crédite le cinéma était en réalité déjà
des trucs de théâtre méliès par exemple
a fait la lune à 1 m on en crée dit
généralement l'imagination de méliès en
réalité il ya eu des plusieurs versions
de set une à un mètre dans les terrasses
de cafés concerts
c'est une figure qui s'inscrit dans une
dans un genre l'affairé ricco mec qui
est un genre de toutes façons de reprise
constante avec je vois des trucs
nouveaux ou mieux fait à chaque reprise
et qui s'étend jusque jeu au début du
20e siècle on monte encore des ferries
et donc méliès intervient à ce moment là
aussi il s'inscrit dans cette continuité
là et à mesure il achève le genre
à
l'un des tout premiers films de méliès
qui s'appelle une nuit terrible
l'histoire d'un homme qui est réveillé
par par des puces c'est exactement le
genre de gars qu'on retrouve dans la
presse illustrée de la même époque
notamment le première fois chez max et
maurice puisque ce sont les deux
garnements qui vont mettre les les
insectes dans le lied d'un adulte on
retrouve donc chez différents
dessinateurs comme ça qu'ils reprennent
ce gars s'est même genre de diack virale
qui se multiplient dans la presse et
après qu'on retrouve dans le cinéma et
les idées circulent et on les reprend
selon les besoins du médium du support
qui va les accueillir
trouve assez passionnant de se dire qu'à
l'époque du cema des premiers temps on a
entre ce qui deviendra la bande dessinée
c'est cette presse illustrée et le
cinéma beaucoup de lieux de convergence
qui sont exploitées avec beaucoup de
points communs la frontalité une
certaine distance à l'objet et que donc
finalement le rapport entre l'endroit
d'où l'on voit et la scène que l'on
filmé ou que l'on dessine que l'on
montre finalement et appréhender un peu
dans avec des mêmes critères qui sont
notamment est bien celui d'une scène
resserré on voit bien que c'est une même
culture visuelle
nos clientes réplique en étudiant les
trois histoires en images que je
considère comme un matériau potentiel à
l'élaboration du film des frères lumière
émise par ubs
on observe que celle de christophe et
très schématique comme un storyboard
parce qu'il n'y a qu'un seul mouvement
de caméra pour suivre l'arroseur dans
son action dans ses déplacements
le reste de l'histoire est dessiné très
précisément tôt ça fonctionne très bien
mais c'est très simple christophe
n'utilise que très peu de technique
cinématographique
l'arroseur arrosé de lumière avait à
être en un plan parce que à ce moment là
c'était très accommode de changer
l'appareil de reprendre un plan et on
n'avait pas l'idée de couper et de dire
nous repartirons de tête de tels points
pour continuer l'histoire tandis que
dans la bande dessinée bon dieu c'était
c'était techniquement plus facile
puisqu'il suffisait d'une plus beaux de
cai ont aidé à bout de papier pour le
réaliser mais je crois que c'est alors
là nous sommes en jeu seraient en faveur
de la version lumière parce que la
technique étant plus difficiles et donne
à moins de facilité il est obligé de
composer plus il est moins libre les
libertés en heure c'est très dangereux
la vue des frères lumière obéit à tous
égards à la structure narrative minimale
il ya un début il ya une fin il ya une
forme de clôture puisque finalement on
temps on laisse le jardinier reprendre
sa position et donc tout ça c'est
vraiment une organisation narrative et
on voit que c'est très rythmé
il ya vraiment une véritable
synchronisation des différentes actions
par rapport aux deux personnages et de
ce point de vue là véritablement une
mise en scène si on regarde la planche
d'hermann fogle l'organisation de
l'espace est beaucoup plus complexe mais
reste maîtrisée seuls y placer le
dessinateur place les protagonistes avec
beaucoup de soin ce seul rouge tous les
uns par rapport aux autres mais l'action
est facile à suivre grâce à un point de
référence unique un banc public placé
dans le décor cela montre une
utilisation très maîtrisée de l'esma
plus compliquée encore fogle change la
position de caméra et par là même celle
du spectateur
et pourtant nous ne sommes pas
désorientés et il y a tout à parier que
le lecteur de l'époque ne l'était pas
non plus même des cous
enfin dans la version d'uzès de 1885
l'expérimentation de ces techniques est
encore plus poussée
le soft on y trouve des quêtes et des
gros plans et également deux images et
très proches l'une de l'autre ce qui
permet de saisir la vitesse de l'action
on peut noter que le point de vue
s'élève et le mouvement part de très bas
et prend de la hauteur au fur à mesure
que le gag progresse aujourd'hui nous
appellerions cette technique un
travelling verticale des saints avait
donc déjà expérimenté certaines
techniques cinématographiques et de fait
avait aussi entraîné leur public à
comprendre des techniques telles que la
caméra mobile les différentes valeurs de
plans les angles de caméra différents
la chose importante que ces plans chacun
cuisine et qu'elle entraîne le public au
langage cinématographique
avant même que le cinéma nexans
rappelez vous avant l'invention des
tuyaux les rues detec frotter en
particulier par les cadets cheveau
nettoyer les chaussées n'était pas chose
facile
l'une des portières avec tordre
d'arroser deux fois par jour les
trottoirs puis d'une pelle en bois
clairement camper devant leur porte
ces gaillards lançait allègrement sur
tous les passants ne puis debout ou dire
des bourgeois ce n'était ni pratique ni
efficace alors var vers 1750 les grands
ono arrosoir le premier que l'on vit
était traîné par quatre hommes pour
rafraîchir les années des tuileries à
certains outre qu'un entrepris de faire
arroser régulièrement les boulevards on
a compté plus de 300 tonneaux dans la
ville de paris et aux dires des
bourgeois ils étaient ni pratique ni
efficace est ce fut enfin l'avènement de
tuyaux en cuir au caoutchouc vulcanisé à
8 francs le mètre ou même en toile un
franc 25 le maître qu elle félicitée
cependant le tuyau restait fragile pour
y remédier ont une astucieuse idée de
fabriquer des manches tubulaire en taule
réunis par des rapports souple en cuir
le tout porté sur de petites roulettes à
6 de puyoô duré deux fois plus longtemps
[Musique]
alors des arroseurs arrosés il va y en
avoir un nom mais absolument
incommensurable en europe aux états unis
j'en ai absolument partout les frères
lumière vont tourner probablement trois
versions de l'arroseur arrosé
la fiche la première affiche de cinéma
celle signée auzolle montre un public en
train de regarder l'arroseur arrosé
ce qui fait que le thème va rentrer dans
l'histoire du cinéma et il va y avoir de
très nombreux copieurs ce gars semblent
être incroyablement populaire et
persistant que s il existe encore
aujourd'hui dans les émissions
télévisées pour enfants et dans les
dessins animés
peut-être parce qu'il permet une
variation illimité de faim c'est un
sujet qui peut être repris et
personnaliser leur tout ce qui le
destine ou en font un film
ils peuvent y apporter leurs propres
variations
m
c'est pas vraiment un gag c'est un gain
de temps en temps par action 3 à 3
c'est c'est plus un effet comique qu'un
gag un gag ça se construit comme un
petit scénario et ça il n'y a pas de
construction fayen une construction mais
c'est simple c'est élémentaire quelqu'un
arrête lockheed sommes choqués de
nouveau quand l'autre on regarde il lève
le pied sur le caillou et il sa rose
donc c'est un effet comique mais très
paisible oui très près l'effet comique
reposerait sur une sanction immédiate
effet comique fait rire tout de suite
dès son apparition alors que le gag
relèverait d'une construction
s'il ya le temps le temps de le faire le
3 devant être mais surprise qui couronne
est qui et qui reprend des éléments de
l'ensemble
exposition d'une situation développement
dans une direction inattendue
et puis retournement qui achève le
développement dans une direction encore
inattendue
[Musique]
m
ya un aspect visuel toujours c'est
capital si le fait de travailler avec
pierre et d'avoir l'interprète principal
à côté de soi aide beaucoup déjà avoir
une première idée de ce que la scène
peut être ensuite il dessine très très
bien donc une série de dessins aident
beaucoup aussi
et puis on faisait avec les aider les
objets qu'on avait longtemps dominé mais
me souviens de toi te cachant derrière
une porte alors là il se mettra derrière
l'arbre la pop tournées à g et ça
c'était formidable parce que on jouait
en même temps qu'ont trouvé les choses
le cinéma les premiers tombent repose
sur des cadrages large dans lesquels les
personnages souvent son indistincte très
vite on va se rendre compte que le
cinéma a tout intérêt à créer des types
on voit des tas de petits films où le
personnage du gamin qui fait des farces
revient sans arrêt tout ça peut être née
des gamins qui vont accrocher des
pétards là que les chiens ou derrière
les cockpits des habits etc
[Musique]
c'est le thème de l'enfant terrible
c'est l'enfant qui nique et
désobéissants qui est ça le qui touche à
tout et c'était ok sans gêne et c'est ça
c'est un thème dans la littérature
enfantine qui apparaît vers les années
1830 fin au début du 19e siècle qui a
déjà généré beaucoup de littérature
enfantine qui sera repris après sous
forme de résidus de récits illustrés ou
d'histoire en images les plus connus au
milieu du 19e siècle celle et max et
maurice de l'allemand vie la bûche est
qui et qui a inspiré après beaucoup
dessinateur donc ce thème de l'enfant
terrible on le retrouve partout après
dans dans les histoires en images pour
adultes mais aussi pour enfants le
garçon qui fait la farce dans l'arroseur
arrosé est identifié comme la droite
trois archétypes qui domine non
seulement la bd les blagues les aussi
les films primitif sur la les formes
peinture of the much is personnage le
garde son malicieux
maintenant il le deuxième marketing et
le campagnard naïve qui se créent des
problèmes en ville car il n'y comprend
rien enfin deux derniers de ces
archétypes et le clochard irrespectueux
plus que le précurseur de happy
hooligans et de fêtes de charlie chaplin
ces trois personnages apparaissent dans
des milliers et des milliers de bd et de
films primés il génère du chaos
une sorte de déséquilibre délicieux et
ida des chars nous aimons voir soit les
pompes peu rabaisser les autorité
bafouée soit la balance et rééquilibrer
la france que j'aime beaucoup que les
citer de mémoire donc sans doute en laon
la défendre un petit peu mais keane une
phrase de tati donc beaucoup plus tard
qui dit qu' un film comique gentil ça
n'existe pas un vrai film comique ne
peut pas ne pas être contestées
or il me semble que ces films ont de
manière souvent très ambigu dimension
contestataire contestation des normes
sociales contestation de la morale même
si à chaque fois l'ordre social ce n'est
pas revenir la morale fini par revenir
le garnement
il prend une fessée est toujours à la
fin comme dans la rose arrosée mais
toujours dans les films qui vont suivre
c'est systématique néanmoins on est
passé auparavant par une phase qui va
consister à
un peu mettre en crise soit la morale
sur l'ordre social
[Musique]
m
est-ce qu intéressant dans ses films
comiques c'est que tous les grands
problèmes sociaux de l'époque sont
abordés dans ses films il ya par exemple
toute une série de films assez
passionnant sur la question du féminisme
sur les suffragettes sur la
revendication des femmes soit à voter
soit être éligible soit travail etc
il ya des séries film passionnant où par
exemple les hommes à la maison des
femmes au travail
bien évidemment lorsqu'on regarde le
film où les films totalité on se dit que
sont plutôt qu'on féminisme mais en même
temps il ya des moments dans ces films
où on voit des hommes qui s'occupent des
bébés et qui prennent un plaisir
incroyable
[Musique]
et
on
certes très souvent avec un retour à
l'ordre moral un retour à l'ordre social
à la fin c'est assez systématique mais
néanmoins à chaque fois le film ans
passera par cette contestation
donc ça va être par exemple le bourgeois
dont on va salir le beau costume qu'il a
achetée très cher
tous les les on pourrait dire des
potentats de l'administration et d'état
sont moqués des magistrats énormément
les hommes politiques énormément
[Musique]
le policier lui il est souvent mise à
mal dans les films comiques dans une
perspective qui va être très largement
reprises par la suite jusqu'au sol
américain avec les équipes stone cops ou
un copte de keaton
[Musique]
et
on voit souvent d'aller dans les toutes
premières bandes films etc étaient à la
plupart du temps file mr d'un jour on
voit quelqu'un qui est devant une pièce
d'eau dans un qui regarde des poissons
quelqu'un de passe derrière lui donne un
coup de pied au cul
le type tombe dans l'eau et ça suffit
quelquefois ça n'allait pas plus loin
que ça que qu'une qu'une chute que une
méprise dans l'ain où simplement
quelqu'un bat s'asseoir en retire la
chaze il tombe par terre pour aider des
choses les plus vieilles montres
[Musique]
l'une d'elles des formes les plus
utilisés du comique tension du premier
temps c'est la poursuite et la poursuite
elle fonctionne sur la réitération sur
l'accumulation c'est à dire qu'en fait
rien ne progresse on circule d'un
endroit à l'autre on est poursuivi on
renverse tout mon cas et meubles mais
fondamentalement il n'y a rien qui
s'enchaînent on pourrait presque
intervertir les plans ça fonctionnerait
il ya des scénarios de films comiques
des années 1900 7908 qui sont conservés
et on se rend compte que ces scénarios
sont sont très peu développé on a par
exemple de sa grotte poursuite et ont
dit ah bah là on va passer rue hôtel rue
en courant
voilà puisqu'on va faire la culbute
faire tomber ceux ci faire tomber ce
n'est pas le scénario se sera improvisé
beaumont et tournage
donc on est dans un comique qui en tout
cas jusqu'aux années 8/10 je dirais
fonctionne beaucoup plus sur ce système
d'accumulation répétition régulation
mais pas construction au sens strict
c'est que c'est un cinéma sans paroles
il vient du cirque du music hall et du
théâtre montval donc la nécessité de
trouver un style nouveau ea a aussi une
de ses raisons dans le fait que ému et
donc il faut que tout soit compris un
peu de temps en temps pour remettre
bientôt un petit canton ici ou là mais
depuis rien il faut que tout soit dans
l'image c'est pour ça qu'on dit souvent
lourd que c'est vraiment de l'invention
du langage cinématographique vient delà
de cette impossibilité de parler ou et
d'expliquer ce que et s'est peu à peu
naturellement plus tard la parole
arrivera et il faudra s'en servir et
derrière pendant un certain temps
elle rencontrera le le cinéma comique à
le ralentir à
[Musique]
l arrosage entrer dans l'ère moderne
désormais à paris 149 brigade
d'arroseurs public cadre il a cité ces
chevaliers du pavé d'un caractère trempé
l'index allongé sur la canule en cuivre
de relance vont pleuvoir des pluies
d'arc en ciel sur plus de 15 hectares de
rue dallée de promenade de gazon est de
champ de navets enfin faut-il vous le
dire mesdames et messieurs le tuyau
d'arrosage et surtout une source de
réjouissance et d'amusement qui exact
nos enfants petits et grands quelle
invention peut se targuer de distiller
avec autant de zèle
cette faculté à faire rire
[Musique]
incontestablement quelque chose change
aux alentours de 1900 c'est tout le sens
où commence à changer pour le dire
rapidement le changement il est
essentiellement sociales des films qui
étaient jusqu'ici pour l'essentiel vendu
les fora acheter leurs copines
deviennent potentiellement aussi loué en
fait les deux systèmes coexistent
jusqu'à 914 c'est à dire que le
projectionniste forains va disparaître
progressivement les films vont être
envoyés dans les salles de cinéma et les
copies ne seront pas vendus à la salle
de cinéma
elles seront loués en échange d'une
partie de la recette
les remontées de royalty sont organisées
on commence à rentrer dans une économie
complètement structure et du cinéma ou
le succès d'un film va arrêter de faire
le succès de l'itinérant mais va faire
le succès du producteur et des
industriels qui ont produit le film
au même moment on va avoir également une
transformation dans le contenu même des
films on avait surtout des films très
courts dans lesquelles il y avait un gag
l'arroseur arrosé et puis après on peut
le répéter ou bien des courses
poursuites ou voilà très souvent le
titre du film résume tout le film ces
films là avec une structure narrative
extrêmement simples et répétitives
progressivement sont concurrencés par
des filles avec une narration beaucoup
plus complexe et on dit qu'on passe d'un
cinéma des attractions comme les
attraction de foire comme quelque chose
de percutant qui va tout d'un coup
secoué le spectateur mais très
brièvement à un cinéma de la narration
on va raconter des choses sur une plus
longue durée à paris en 1910 c'est assez
clair mandaté parce que quand on fait
les programmes on se rend compte de
manière très précise les éditeurs de
films donc les producteurs mais qui à
l'époque s'appelait l'éditeur propose on
va dire un nouveau genre comique
il faut prendre ici comico sens vraiment
génériques ou une sorte de sous georges
pas comment l'appeler en tout cas on
voit que certains films sont rendus dans
une classification nouvelle qui est la
classification comédie sans doute parce
que ce qui se joue c'est aussi l'intérêt
d'un public plus cultivés pour ce cinéma
comique là et donc ce public cultivé est
plutôt demandeur de quelque chose qui
relèverait de la comédie moins triviale
moins grotesque plutôt basé sur des
situations invraisemblables
avec un jeu moins outrancier
[Musique]
il faut se rendre compte que dans les
toutes premières années les gens de
théâtre au sens un peu noble du terme
ont un vrai mépris pour le cinéma et non
seulement ils ont un mépris pour le
cinéma mais souvent ou très vite en tout
cas on va par contre à leurs intérieurs
de jouer au cinéma parce que c'est
dévaloriser leur image c
si on interdit c'est parce qu'on a un
moment où des gauches et de fait ce
notamment dans le genre comique on va
voir arriver des gens qui viennent du
théâtre plus classique des gens comme
max under qui un fait le conservatoire
de bordeaux
[Musique]
on va retrouver max chez sa concierge
max qui fait du ski max qui fait du
patinage etc
c'est une démarche totalement nouvelle
c'est la naissance du star system et le
star system et finalement l'ouverture
d'un cinéma totalement industriels on
prend une vedette qu'on a déjà formaté
qu'on a déjà vendu en termes de
marketing et on l'a fait se déplacer et
toutes les semaines le spectateur vient
regarder sa vedette dans une situation
nouvelle
[Musique]
et ce qui est tout neuf tout à fait
nouveau c'est que dans les comédies on
parle même si évidemment les films sont
muets on voit des personnages qui
parlent on va recourir à l'interdît
titre on va recourir à des situations
vraisemblable à des ressorts
psychologiques
voilà je me sens humilié parce que ma
femme a trompé et c'est donc tout ça
fait que le comique change de tonalité
en même temps que le système de
replantation change
on va commencer à faire des gros plans
qui n'ont pas pour vocation à faire des
grimaces parce que dans les premiers
temps c'est aussi beaucoup ça en commun
dans les films de durand donc sa
deuxième génération apporte quelque
chose de résolument nouveau qui pour
certains en tout cas va le théâtre mais
au sein de cette deuxième génération de
nos talents de metteur en scène
on a aussi des gens qui viennent
d'autres univers à ces nouveaux qui sont
par exemple la caricature c'est emile
cohl c'est jean durand et qui vont
apporter un univers totalement différent
basé sur l'absurde basé sur dix ans un
comique très physique
et
la série les jo mars et la rencontre
assez inattendue entre un comique plutôt
théâtrale à lalinde air et en même temps
tout ce qui relève effectivement de
l'absurde de la grimace de l'outrance et
c'est donc il n'y a pas forcément
d'opposition en tout cas il ya deux
systèmes comique qui discute on pourrait
dire l'un avec l'autre
à partir des années des années 10 et à
la fin des années 10 on est rentrés dans
l'ère moderne du cinéma avec une
économie avec des lieux de projection
avec des projecteurs sédentarisés et en
gros les forains vont devenir
progressivement quelque chose de très
marginale dans l'histoire du cinéma
même s'ils resteront jusqu'à la fin des
années 30 le cinéma français était le
premier cinéma du monde le plus gros
exportateur dans le monde entier
gaumont pathé méliès puis éclair luxe
etc
donc il avait un quasi-monopole cercle
vraiment ils dominaient largement tous
les marchés cinématographique y compris
les états unis
et puis aux alentours 1910 1911 1912 il
commence à voir des compagnies aux états
unis qui sont plus puissantes qui
propose des nouvelles choses extra qui
exportent leurs films
on a fait des recherches notamment
statistiques sur la la présence des
films étrangers en france avant la
guerre on se rend compte qu'en 1912 et
les films français sont minoritaires en
france donc c'est pas la guerre qui
vient déboulonner le cinéma français
c'est un processus qui est déjà qui est
déjà commencée qui bien sûr va
s'accentuer avec la guerre est donc le
ca comique pâtit aussi de sa pâti de
cette concurrence américaine pâtit bien
sûr de la guerre et puis on peut pas
nier qu effectivement un comique un peu
différent
culturellement différents arrive avec
les américains
ce cinéma comique notamment avec chaplin
part et ne rien devoir au théâtre on
pourrait discuter mais en tout cas c'est
comme ça qu'il est vu par et en plus
contenir un discours social très fort
donc à agréger un petit peu comme ça
deux qualités qui vont lui donner toute
suite une reconnaissance très fort c'est
un cinéma comique différents qui a été
inspiré par max linder par les comiques
français les pouic durand et ses
calinaud voilà tous les gens chez
gaumont et pathé ont créé un comique
burlesque très très puissant très fort
très destructeur au niveau du matériel
au niveau de la pensée aussi
l'anarchiste on peut dire d'une certaine
façon et il ya comme une prise de relais
d'une certaine façon avec le cinéma
américain qui va lui donc standardisés
un petit peu les formes de ce burlesque
qui partaient dans tous les sens avec
les gens comme chaplin puis dans les
années 20 keaton laurel et hardy etc
[Musique]
qu'y at-il de drôle dans ce gag c'est
l'air soit un tuyau d'arrosage apprîmes
b prime branché d'une part et robinet
granta et d'autre part elle lance
d'arrosage grand p et c'est un
personnage grande et qui a posé son pied
petite déprime sur le tuyau le lève
brusquement l'eau jaillit avec force
[Musique]
toujours jarre 11 jaro a pleinement tout
le temps et d'arroser sa langue en
arrosant deschamps moi mais je m'arme
aux 2 h mar lô je déteste la peau on se
dit quand je vois dissipateur dans de
beaux habits croire quelque chose vous
rafraîchir tout ces pauses
je vous le rappelle yves herman